hey guys welcome to a special pandemic
edition of the evidence island podcast
[Music]
we put the jolly music okay this this
has been an interesting podcast to
brainstorm because it's a difficult
situation no we're in I mean like like a
lot of times I think humans model their
behavior after other people to like not
break social norms and stuff and it's
it's a weird place to be in right now
because it seems like this is the first
time I guess in our lives or something
this crazy has happened yeah so we're
just gonna do our best but we've been
wondering were you saying that like so
no one has other people to model after
is that what the connection was yeah
yeah kinda knows let's do it no one
knows what to do we don't know what to
do we never know what to do and I guess
things work out okay so that's what
we're going to try to do today we wanted
to kind of just talk about the situation
talk about how we're doing talk about
what's going on on our side of things
from the personal and business side of
things and see where it goes yeah and we
went back and forth about like you know
should we not do any content specific to
what's going on
or should we talk about things but you
know what it's kind of like what's on
our mind and yeah for the podcast it
just seemed right to kind of talk about
the stuff that's been going on lately
cuz we haven't had a podcast for two
weeks we've recorded one for two weeks
and so and there's an extreme it's an
extreme understatement to say that a lot
has changed in two weeks yeah I mean the
initial event was more than two weeks
ago but like the past two weeks is when
things have really accelerated rapidly
yeah we want to try to keep our main
channel and our gaming channels a
escape from all of this harsh reality
yeah welcome to our fun jolly podcast
everybody it's close enough to the
beginning let's let's yeah it's perfect
it's perfect to just how it is so yes I
guess we should start by saying like so
we want we did want to share kind of how
things have been for us but I feel like
we should start by acknowledging that we
were in a very very very lucky position
yeah very lucky you know our our work is
the type of work that we can do from
home it's how we work anyway so um you
know we've been able to keep on working
our families are safe
we haven't gotten sick like you know
we've been able to get what we need
generally so far so like we're in a very
lucky position yeah but it's still weird
and we are trying to look into ways to
help by the time this goes live yes well
party will already have been done our
very first charity event it was a
charity livestream hopefully that went
well yeah it's tomorrow tomorrow
like it's our first charity like
livestream event is our first charity
event ever I think
we've contributed to charities before
but oh we did see team trees trees so
it's our second charity event yeah but a
livestream events like a whole other
thing so we're a little nervous about
how that's gonna go but by the time you
guys are listening it's done so
hopefully what oh yeah also I know that
like in the maker community there's a
lot of people getting involved with 3d
printing and people yeah and I think
that that's that's really cool and I
really love all of the groups that are
doing it I think that right now the the
situation is is changing so rapidly
day to day there's all sorts of designs
there are already people who are like
organizing and vetting these designs out
there that are doing a good job I think
that it would be good to add our voice
and amplify something at the right
moment but it's just been a such a
rapidly changing thing and we're not on
like the inside scoop of any of it so we
didn't want to like start pushing
something too early before we knew that
it had been confirmed as the correct
thing to push yeah
because we've also heard there's been a
lot of tweets about oh don't do that
mass design that's a that's a bad wine
like that's gonna give people a false
sense of security like there's so much
missing
things are a little bit more sure and we
can make a push in the best direction
instead of maybe accidentally pushing
something that isn't it as ideal and I
know that it's a little bit crazy out
there and you know I think that
everyone's is trying to do their best to
help yeah you know it is really
encouraging that there are so many
wonderful people out there doing so many
wonderful things and helping out in all
these incredible ways yeah but we
thought the best the best thing that we
could do that we felt the most sure
about was just directly raising cash you
know for this event
and giving it to the people who are like
in place with experienced resources and
connections to like make some big things
happen because this is what is needed
right now like that there's there's a
lot going on at local levels and there's
a lot going on at the worldwide level so
I think everyone helping in whatever way
is grateful way works best for them yeah
so thank you everyone who's doing
awesome things and and you know what one
way to help
it's just stay inside which is what
we've been doing a lot of recently we
have we've been officially self
quarantine for I think 14 days now yeah
I mean of course you know we go out for
supplies food not yeah not supplies just
food yeah yeah we go out for food
because humans need that to survive yeah
but that'sthat's pretty much been it I
think that yeah the only person I've
seen in terms of a face is my what
lovely wife you know some restaurants
you know we've done drive-thru a couple
times and then some restaurants are
doing like deliveries now that maybe
didn't use to so we've gotten deliveries
when we can yeah a lot of cooking big
meals that we can freeze and like I
started that like over a month ago yeah
yeah Caitlin has been like on top of
things
yeah yeah like over a month ago I
started like when I would go to the
grocery store I just get stuff for an
extra freezer meal that week and so I'd
make extra freezer meal so we and my
freezer meal basically we have like a
general life strategy because we we'd
stay pretty busy with all of the five
YouTube channels and twitch account that
we like put content out on might change
my future who knows so basically our one
of our big strategies for cooking
efficiently in terms of food as we make
as big of a batch of food as possible
especially when it's something that can
freeze or yeah basically freeze well
lots of stews lots of sauces I think we
have maybe talked about it before so we
kind of stockpiled a lot of stockpiles
of a very negative word we responsibly
gathered a few extra few extra meals
food but the thing is because this is
what we do regularly like I got an insta
pot and we use that thing at least once
or twice a week when we're cooking and
so we already like it feels like we
prepped more than we did just sounds
like we already had stuff in our in our
freezer because that's just like the way
that we cook as we try to make more than
we need and then freeze it it's really
really efficient to do that like in
terms of using resources to like kayln
is a
a master chef when it comes to using a
hundred percent of the resources that
you don't like throwing things away it
makes me very upset it literally does he
get hurt we have like a small amount of
takeout fried rice left over in the
fridge and I'm like it's like two
spoonfuls of rice but like I might go
hungry for that right so I think Caitlyn
has been doing a most of the groceries
and procuring stuff honestly okay so
I'll admit I have not been to the
grocery store in two weeks
my last grocery trip was the last time
we like either of us went out in a
public place and like were around more
than just like the person at the
drive-through window that were very
carefully handed our card to and we have
a whole system where it's like one of us
has like when we pick up food one of us
has the dirty hands and one of us has
the clean hands so like like Evan will
be driving so he's got the clean hand so
I like hold the food and I hold it very
carefully I don't let it touch anything
and then Evan unbuckles me and lets me
out of the car and I like you know go
over we like carefully remove it onto
our plates and I throw it away the outer
bag wash my hands really good so it's
like I think I'm driving so Kalin like
leans across me like I'll take that
ma'am thank you we have a system down
it's better safe than sorry and in a lot
of ways you know playing it safe but
yeah so so we haven't been to the
grocery store in two weeks and like I'm
not gonna lie I have a little anxiety
about going just coz so my past few
grocery trips the most reason being two
weeks ago and the ones before that being
maybe like four or five days prior every
trip changed so much like the first trip
there was like you know the toilet paper
was a little picked over um but there's
so like a few things their second trip
no no oh yeah and there's no ham
sanitizer second trip no toilet paper no
hand sanitizer but like everything else
is pretty much normal
that third trip which was two weeks ago
it was
it was like yeah you know when like a
hurricane comes into town and everyone's
buying up everything it was more than
that more picked over and weird and just
things that I didn't expect to be gone
we're gone like there was like almost no
meat which I didn't expect
oh yeah because you need it well I guess
you can freeze meat yeah you can freeze
me but it's just like you know I
expected like the toilet paper to be
gone the canned foods the frozen foods I
expected like that stuff
there was like no chicken and I was like
I need you to confirm the recipe so it's
gonna make so I found like the frozen
organic chicken breasts that were very
expensive and I was like well I guess
you know and it's it was just weird you
know and I haven't been back since and I
have like a whole game plan for when I
do go like I'm gonna bring a paper list
so that I'm not having to touch my phone
a bunch and I can just throw the list
away after like you know we have gloves
because we use gloves for resin so I'm
gonna wear gloves mostly because like
having the gloves on will be a really
good reminder for me to not touch my
face which is the hardest thing yeah I'm
kind of nervous honestly I've been
putting it off we just I was gonna go
this morning before we launched our
video but yesterday we got a hello fresh
shipment in and so I was like okay yeah
on the project front and ordering things
online we have had to put off one
project because understandably things
are taking a little bit longer to come
come in I mean I know Amazon and UPS and
FedEx and everyone are prioritizing
urgent parcels which totally makes sense
I mean our very specific requirements
for those like weird obscure project are
not high priority no so we've had to
adjust our projects um you know it is a
little weird when you see like an Amazon
Prime
delivery item not be like estimated to
show up for a month and you're like whoa
yeah that's that's
there's been a lot of things that have
hit me and that was just another one I
like you know because we've gotten so
used to just instant fulfillment of all
of our needs and we build our lives
around it we build our schedules around
it and yeah like how many videos are we
gonna have to postpone it because a lot
of the stuff we we need for the projects
it's not high priority from a like
average person's needs yeah perspective
yeah so I mean hopefully we won't have
to postpone any more we might though
like we had to we had to get a little
creative with this week's video using
stuff we had which was totally fun
honestly like I really liked doing the
resin mixing it was a fun excuse to do a
project that had been on our list yeah
and it was uh yeah I I'm happy with how
the video turned out and everything
still but there's also like sponsored
delays it's completely understandable
you know sponsors our businesses too and
they you know have to run their business
responsibly and and when they need to
adjust their marketing budgets around I
think they're like it's this is a great
time to be very considerate
understanding and compassionate of other
people other businesses everybody for
all circumstances I feel like this is
like a an important time to like
practice understanding compassion and
forgiveness because this is completely
unprecedented and you know it's it's
interesting there there have been a lot
of people warning about this and asking
people to prep but it is also hard
because until it happens it's not real
and it's just it's kind of like
procrastination everyone understands
procrastination you know it's like oh
that's so far away and the likelihood
isn't that high we'll deal with that
later
oh well probably should have done that
sooner yeah well and I feel like we were
kind of started thinking about things
like ahead
other friends and family members that
one thing like about government oh like
the world like like big institutions and
businesses and and everything I think
it's also another thing I mean it's it's
tough because you know the world runs on
business finances like smart business
decisions hustle hustle hustle money
money money money yeah and stuff but
like preparing for eventualities isn't
like a it's a smart financial decision
if happen if it eventually happens and
the preparations you made were the right
ones but it's you know no one has
crystal balls no one
also things like smaller businesses
don't have the ability to prepare like
bigger businesses can set aside cash to
like ride the wave but smaller
businesses don't always have that luxury
yeah like I know a lot of people um are
talking about how they're like getting
gift cards to local restaurants like
that which i think is cool I've also
heard like some concern because then
you're just like delaying the time where
they won't get paid but I think the
difference is like if if no one's buying
food or gift cards from them right now
it's one concentrated chunk of making no
money and that can like put a business
under whereas if you buy the gift cards
and yes that means you're not paying
later when you eat it's not like
everyone as soon as they can leave their
house are gonna go like redeem every
single gift card
they made immediately all at the same
time I think that like spread out when
when the restrictions release what are
some of the first things that we're
gonna do I'll probably eat out they'd
probably eat out a lot
hang out and your parents pool yeah hang
out of the pool like go got to eat and
then hang out yeah guys hang out with
family that sounds like a great great
choice
yeah that's really I mean that's the
main thing we did outside of our house
before this is go out to eat they hang
out with family firmware that's it um
so again very lucky you know it's not as
big of an adjustment for us as it would
be for people like working in offices or
you know people who have kids whose kids
are now at home with them yeah um you
know it's much much bigger adjustment
people we canceled a trip that we had
but that's we're supposed to leave in
two days two days for our first vacation
in a year and a half and it's a small
thing to give up yeah I mean I was
looking forward to it we we postponed it
till the fall just goes like the
summer's too hot yeah
and so we postponed it to the fall so
it'll it'll still be happening but then
it'll be two years on a vacation you
know what's the thing make your everyday
life like a vacation by working every
day with your favorite person with your
favorite person doing something that you
love yeah and hopefully entertaining
people yeah or at least hanging out with
them in podcast form I'm not sure what
this is right now this is more like a
hangout with like us is this
entertaining or is this more hangout
probably more hangout I feel like
podcaster more like hanging out podcast
more hanging out I mean there are
entertainment podcasts out there yeah
but sometimes those are like too much
for me my favorite podcasts tend to be
more chill ones more chill yeah I think
there's my favorite too yeah what do you
think um
so it's interesting because a lot of
people I are kind of expressing the
sentiment and again we're very lucky
that we can work our our work schedule
if anything has gotten a little bit this
is even more stressful because we've had
to do a lot of last-minute like
switcheroos there's just a more added on
top yeah yeah more added on top and then
it's also it's honestly like well we'll
be doing okay we'll kind of be like in
our zone working on stuff things feel
pretty normal and then something like
the you know the Amazon Prime shipment
isn't going out until late April and
then you're like snapped back into
reality for a second by some little
trigger and then
you go down a rabbit hole of news
articles and everything else though it's
um anyways what I what I was getting to
is like um a lot of people have asked
like what are you guys doing with the
free time or said like oh you guys
should do this in your free time or you
guys should do that in your free time
and I do wish we had a little bit more
free time right now even though I'm
grateful that we are still able to work
we have we have no buffer we don't have
any videos lying ahead
we're not ahead in any way on any front
and our to-do list is fairly long
somehow fairly long still yeah um but my
question for you yes is in a
hypothetical world where we just did
free up time for us what would you want
to do it would be a mix of streaming
games on Twitch
which we have increased significantly
have yep so we are kind of doing that we
are kind of doing that and getting a
pool installed in our backyard so we can
hang out there I I wonder if people are
installing pools right now I mean I know
like I know that a lot of a lot of work
has been paused like housement work and
like you know third-party contracting
type stuff somehow things are still
continuing like house necessary house
maintenance stuff but you know some of
that like in the law of the hard-hit
areas it's fully stopped like hard stats
yeah and there's no work being done it
really depends on where you are in that
in the u.s. in the world what the
current level of the lockdown and stuff
is my guess is we would have a hard time
finding someone to install a pool what's
your next back-up plan order an
inflatable pool off Amazon order and
enjoy in one month you know Sofia did
order an inflatable hot tub that's true
we could order an inflatable hot tub off
Amazon build a deck from the scrap wood
that we have hmm that would be a very
patchwork deck we
two-by-fours we have walnut we have then
we have 3/4 inch acrylic very weird
cut-offs of sheet goods we got a bunch
of resin cubes just like what we do is
we form a wall in our yard and we just
pour a resin slab and we set up the hot
tub on top of that resin slab oh yeah we
already have a concrete slab patio okay
so we put the inflatable hot tub on the
patio and then we hop in there and we
read whatever you um so in a slightly
more realistic situation where we're not
building a deck well I guess here as you
knew nixed the deck yeah yeah we just
order the inflatable hot tub and we said
it was only when it's running what we
can do is we can let it run heat up turn
everything off oh yeah and then profit
um I think I would definitely want to
spend some time reading I want to watch
some movies oh yeah that'd be great we
have a pop-up projector screen you watch
from the hot tub watch from the hot tub
there to spend all of our time in a hot
tub
I also been watching movies I also
really want to like go through the house
and organize things and this is a desire
I have it all time when think the busier
things are the less we have a chance to
like deal with the stuff that
accumulates and we accumulate more stuff
than most people because we're doing
projects every weekend precious acquired
tools and materials and then we have
like a thing that we've made at the end
of it which is why I really like when
our projects just result in a few small
resin cubes that's great watch the store
or deal with um but I would like to like
work on the house some in ways that
aren't really interesting for a video
you know just like organizing
getting rid of stuff that we don't need
that kind of thing which there are a
decent amount yeah I'm just like looking
around our office right now yeah looking
at my desk Katelyn side has stayed very
nice my side is busy with projects that
are ongoing right now right now that's a
project I'm working on
that's true leds leds yeah so it's
justified I'd like to I'd like to like
take the time to work on the house a
little bit because I think that would be
fun and it would make me feel good I
really want to redo this room that might
be a video projects I'm somewhere down
the line yeah our office be crazy
speaking of main channel videos and
projects and stuff like that I think
that that for for the time being and I
don't really know how long this is gonna
last I don't think that we are in a
proper position to like guess at how
long in this current situation might
last check the proper governmental
agency in your area announcement anyways
for us personally I think that we're
gonna be moving to an every other week
schedule for our main videos we're a lot
of reasons yeah it's it's only partially
because of the stuff going on honestly
I'm like I think that there's been a lot
of things again and again and again that
have made us realize that we are running
our business on too narrow of an edge
does that make sense - yeah fine if a
margin yeah we don't we're we do when
nothing unexpected is when everything is
fine everything's fine can right along
we are making videos we are outputting
things we are feeling great everything
is good one unexpected likes like a
small unexpected wrench really this way
yeah and and that's when we realized
like we're we're writing on such a thin
margin timewise that like those little
unexpected things that are kind of
guaranteed to happen throw us off so
much
I think that we planned our schedule
we've been running our business as if
it's the only thing that exists and
because of that that's the only thing
that can exist but that doesn't take
into account all of the things that are
inevitable taxes okay swapping merge
providers those two things alone this
year have been like so much
I know we've liked mention it in passing
but a lot of like things changed on the
tax and the merge stuff is all related
to tax stuff but we totally switch merch
stores have so much back end tax stuff
we're still trying to like figure things
out but there's also there's always
going to be inevitable thing that's like
that that pop up and then there's going
to be completely unexpected things like
a worldwide pandemic you know it's like
we hopefully not always hopefully not
always hopefully this is one time and
then we're done
but there we didn't we didn't build any
buffer like when we started evident
Catelynn we started it with the
intention of like alright let's just go
a hundred percent all out put everything
in and that's what we've been doing for
three years but like with that strategy
there isn't what's that I just realized
something
what's that three days ago was our
three-month channel anniversary three
days ago from the day we're recording
three days ago was a three-year a
three-year our three-year channel
anniversary Channel Anniversary happy
anniversary so we're just crazy the
stuff is going on I did oh my gosh three
years Wow from when we post our first
video our first batch of videos cuz we
did like five Wow
weird right weird and we haven't we
haven't slowed down one bit we've
changed we've evolved we've yeah a lot
of it honestly is like starting in the
podcast out in the gaming like we
started a lot of other stuff you know
when we first started or even things
like merch and patreon like all these
various parts of the of the business we
weren't doing in the very beginning so
we were like working putting more hours
into videos maybe not at the very
beginning because we were working for
yeah we were working full-time but once
we quit our jobs and we were doing Evan
and Caitlin full-time I think we were
putting more time just into the video
yeah but also it's like we didn't have a
business oh all it was was making videos
we didn't we did we weren't like we
weren't running a business it was just
it was just barely enough of a business
to give us the confidence to quit our
job we quit our jobs we had been doing
more of the business things like dealing
with sponsors and scheduling and
invoicing and you know shutting
ourselves up for long term success and
strategizing and and stuff but it's just
like it's all just become more as we've
become a bigger channel and a bigger
company
you know logistics happen and in your so
that's a story for another time it's not
really related to this moment right now
the main thing is but I think that I
think the main thing is we've just
realized that we're running on too thin
of a margin and we're just gonna pull
back our schedule that doesn't
necessarily mean longer-term we're not
gonna be making the same amount of
videos it's just we're not gonna
pre-commit yes as many videos and that's
that's the main thing that has gotten us
in trouble it's like Caitlin and I take
our commitments very seriously Caitlin
it completely makes sense why she takes
things very seriously she's been
straight-a student her entire life she's
like very very rule-abiding not that I
am rule-breaking
necessarily I'm a little bit more
chaotic
I in general I'm just very chaos and go
with the flow but at the same time I
take a lot of pride in my word that's
like the main thing that I'm like a real
stickler on like I'm very serious about
like if I commit to something I really
get done it's gonna get done other than
that I'm like why whatever that's why I
like side tangent that's why on the
gaming channel we don't have a schedule
if I said we are alive every Monday
Wednesday and Saturday at 1:00 p.m. CST
oh man that'd be very stressful because
I want to add one only live again the
charity stream is over now but like this
is one of the few times where we have
committed to a time on the stream and
only so much stress now I'm stressed
what if there's audio issues what if
there's issues with the game what if our
world needs to update what if like all
these things it's like we have to like
prepare in the morning but then it's
gonna fail because it's been on to for
too long you know we we take our
commitments very seriously and that's
why I like when we commit to the
sponsors and and our channel and all of
that the schedule that we are on with
the main channel it's like we just can't
deviate like when something comes up our
solution isn't to put it off it's like
like like to put off our commitments or
to reap move around our commitments our
solution is just to work longer into the
night and take less breaks
pat pat that's our solution this is just
work more yeah so I think like if if we
start committing to and every other week
instead of you know what we're doing
right now
that doesn't mean that there won't be
potentially bonus videos yeah if we get
ahead and we have time to do bonus
videos or we've even talked about like
maybe doing some second channel stuff a
blowout in cooking video poking videos
in the shop that'd be that'd be yeah we
have a hot plate we have a hot plate we
can get more hot plates if we need to
you know it'd be really fine
and there's there's almost like a lot of
like second channel type stuff that we
wanted to do just it's just lower
pressure which one also it's like growth
opportunities not from a channel point
of view not from like a business point
of view it's just it's a dumb business
idea it doesn't make sense from a
business perspective especially short
term but like from a growth perspective
as like content creators as people as
like feeding your curiosity and and
growing and and stuff I feel like it is
a wise thing to do to free up because
like I I feel confident that we can just
keep on making Evan and Caitlin videos
the videos we've been making and slowly
evolving as we evolve and you know
slowly growing and then I love our
evident videos but the way we got to
where we're at now is by experimenting
but at the same time as Evan and Caitlin
videos have gotten bigger and we have a
bigger audience there's like almost more
expectations for consistency there's
almost more of a back catalog you know
it's like we're almost more locked into
a course in some ways I don't know yeah
maybe I mean I've never felt like too
locked in just cuz like we do
continually we do I just but going back
to what you're saying and second it go
about like good business decisions an
interesting thing is like like you're
saying the best business decision is
just to double down on the evident
Caitlyn main channel but if we did that
we wouldn't have this podcast we
wouldn't have the gaming channel yeah
you know but also I just don't think
that would have enough time to recharge
between our main videos so that we can
make more good videos because guys I'm
not sure if you know this if you've
watched some of our live streams you
probably do we suck at acting we we are
terrible at acting and like we want to
make fun videos where we're enthusiastic
and we have like all this energy and
like if we just kept on pumping out the
very similar types of videos I feel like
I don't think I'd get stale but I think
that like trying the gaming channel
trying the podcast has mixed things up
in a good way that has made our main
videos even better you know it's
introduced new like the whole green
screen oh my gosh yes so many of our
videos like it's benefited our main
channel videos a lot by having the green
screen by having this experience and and
I think in a way starting the podcast
has let us have words be less hard you
know I feel slightly better at speaking
and that has helped us for the gaming
channel it's all kind of circulating
also like so you don't have we don't
want to give anything up so we're just
like pulling back slightly on the thing
that is the by far the biggest time suck
yeah give ourselves a little bit more
margin especially like when things are a
little bit extra crazy like you don't
know what a unexpected thing it's gonna
pop up yep so you know but on the flip
side we kind of mentioned this in
passing earlier we have been trying to
livestream more yep on Twitch um cuz
hanging out has been really nice like
for even from from a selfish perspective
it's been really nice just like hanging
out with you guys yeah I think it's it's
definitely like good for our mental
health like after each livestream we're
like so pumped yeah we're always like
like yeah do something I don't know what
it is or let's go eat we all consume
right before night streams when we
stream after dinner but it is it is a
great recharge it is a great like
re-energize and and I don't know that's
good also it's like I think we've talked
about this before we've talked about the
gaming channel it's like we we have been
gamers our whole lives and when we
started Evan and Caitlin we stopped
gaming because it wasn't conducive to
business and turning it into a business
has been a good excuse for us to play
games again which we really enjoy oh my
gosh
there's so many games I just like would
love to play all the time I want to play
games every single day but I also want
to play video videos I also want to make
videos for you guys to enjoy so it's
like I feel like we're balanced in each
and when we have been working on a video
for like a week or two then like
breaking it up with with streaming games
in the middle has been really great and
then it's like great to go back to
filming and it's great to go back to
editing it's great to go back to to
playing games and shaming it and it's
like yeah it's kind of like when we're
eating meals both of us have like a
strategy we like we don't like to just
eat the same like you know we're like if
we went to get pizza we all get pizza
and a salad so that we can never buy the
pizza abiders out the way a menu is set
up is you order your appetizer first and
then you order your honor you know and
your entree they bring the appetizer you
finish your appetizer and they bring the
entree we're like no we would like that
salad and the pizza at the same time
please and thank you even weird things I
think that there is a place where we had
oh the brunch and the brunch brunch and
pasta we were telling my brother about
the story and he looked at me very weird
I think my sister this is before
everyone was cool but we went to this
Italian place and realized they were
serving brunch and we really wanted the
French toast and we also really wanted
the pasta and like burrata cheese so we
asked for all three of them at the same
time so we can alternate and have like a
bite of french toast a bite of cheese -
pasta alternate it like clears your
palate of the thing that you've been
doing and you've been tired of and it
gets you like it makes the next one
because like you you guys know the first
bite you take of something so good Wow
Wow delicious your tastebuds are all
neutral and they're all just sleepy and
they get hit with that like tasty flavor
and they're like wow yeah
yeah and then they get tired of cheering
for a while for that flavor and then
like it's not as fully tasty but if you
if you like throw something new at them
then they're like wow again and then
there's a party all the time
that same analogy but for our life and
making videos playing games and
podcasting thank you thank you I I like
to do it also made me hungry
[Laughter]
yes that's a that's an update from us
that's kind of a big one yeah we we went
back and forth about I already mentioned
how we went back and forth about like
talking about it like I think we said
we've gone back and forth about a lot of
things we we have like one do we make
this podcast where we talk about
difficult subjects like are we gonna
handle it right I don't know
cuz we don't we don't I just sound like
we are complaining yeah um but we also
want to share with you guys what's going
on yeah you know um so it almost it even
though you know we do worry because we
don't want things to sound like like
we're not grateful for the very lucky
position that we're in we also worried
that if we didn't talk about how things
work we're going on it would feel like
disingenuous just doesn't genuine
genuine so it doesn't genuine it's
another fine line we have to walk yeah
and we want to be like at least some
amount of fun I know that you guys
getting exposed to that all the time and
we don't want to be another like I don't
know we'd like to be a brighter spot in
your day if at all possible so that's
that I think that's like the main thing
that like we've really been focusing on
you know I think that's why we've been
trying to stream a lot like I know that
people have left some comments that they
like our main channel videos and and
like it kind of helps them be distracted
and everything and
we try to we're just trying to make as
much content as we can I don't know if
it helped making our merchants too thin
without yeah well while also taking care
of ourselves that we can make the
content that we are proud of yeah yeah
hey you know something I just realized
what's that I didn't prepare a thing of
the week I didn't prepare thing of the
week either why don't you keep on
talking on the main subject and I'll
quickly think of a thing of the week
while you keep the podcast running away
because I want to give I want to give
like a content thing of the week other
than a sing thing of the week because
like who knows if you'll be ordered to
aunt or able to order it on it yeah my
thing of the week that I thought of is
sold out right now so yeah let's think
of either a video we watched recently
either a video or a content creator or a
podcast or something along those lines
or game a game oh I I could oh I can
choose a game my thing of the week is
the forest oh it's so fun I know the
forest oh my gosh we've probably talked
about minecraft before I hope that's
been the thing of a week bonus thing of
the week let's talk let's talk about
some some interesting games if you're
playing a game with with younger kids
play Minecraft it's unlimited
you can play forever you you make your
own objectives you can like the other
day we've turned our mountain house into
a cat yep which eye is glowing eyes it's
great like youyou we're gonna there's so
many adventures we want to have there's
so much that we want to do in Minecraft
and it's completely family friendly yeah
if you want a less family-friendly
version of Minecraft play before it's
extreme it's a little bit more realistic
here so basically you're on a plane you
crash land on an island there are
cannibals and there are mutants on the
island but the interesting thing is like
they like everything is very intuitive
you pick up a rock you pick up some
sticks you wrap cloth around the - you
got a stone axe you want to build a
bridge gather some logs
some trees chop down some trees and it's
very interesting honestly you know when
you're in between the confrontations
with the cannibals it's like kind of a
nice chill game
you're just out in the woods building
treehouses but then anytime you can get
raided by cannibals you're freaking out
and you're running around you're you're
crow you're shooting them with your bow
and you're stabbing them with your spear
and then the scariest thing is there's
caves which has the really good loot but
like in the caves there's limited
visibility there's you can't run away
it's so freaky and scary oh my gosh so
the forest is it's a good game it's an
older game but I'm not sure if it's like
gotten like huge exposure I'm not sure
if it's a big game that everyone's heard
about so yeah it might be a nice little
gem for you guys to pick up we're
playing it on PC we're playing on two
different computers multiplayer and it's
nice oh you know it'd also be good for
what words are hard if you're away from
your friends or family and you want to
hang out with them go ahead and boot up
into the forest or into one of these
multiplayer games call them on the phone
and like it's great to hang out co-op
you know do something together like it's
a great hangout it's a great hangout
like whenever I like
I'm doing any reading or anything like
that in the forest almost there's so
many people who played it like
multiplayer and there I remember I built
a base here on this one Delta and it was
so fun we like did you know there's
always like memories and I don't know
it's a great shared experience how about
that yeah okay Caitlin what's your thing
of the week I was thinking the week I
saved this video I found where my ideas
for thing of the week okay it is from a
channel called Kat Navi desk I don't
know much about this channel but I saw
this one video because it was going
viral it's called cats and dominoes and
oh my gosh so we'll have a link but it's
the best the best thing
and you know I know like caravel there's
there's a whole like domino videos are
like a thing on YouTube very satisfying
to watch but adding cats in the mix and
they interact and have to like do
certain things they're part of the
Dominos part of the dominos and these
cats are just like the best today they
take their sweet time the timing of it
is the best part of it the timing of the
suspense it's it's a three minute long
video they might I'm not sure um so this
channel has two hundred forty thousand
subscribers we have not explored their
other stuff yet though I do want to
there's two cats
this video has eight point nine really
good you might have seen already but if
you just want to like escape reality
from three and a half minutes and watch
some cats and dominoes like it is great
it is quality content quality Caitlin
stands by that stand by it we'll have a
link to to Minecraft
we'll have a link to the forest omaha
will link to this cat and domino video
yeah alright guys well this has been an
unusual episode of the evident Kailyn
podcast I hope you guys are staying safe
out there we really appreciate you guys
tuning in to our content we really like
just like I'm just sending you guys a
big virtual hug if you're watching the
video this is very awkward if you're
listening I'm just gonna hug the
microphone right now can you hear it can
you hear my hug my hug
whenever you're listening to this all
right well um yeah it's weird to wrap
this up but anyways stay safe and we'll
look for you next time
[Music]